I don't know I just felt like if Georgia
had gone into overtime they were
probably gonna stay in the top four Pat
forty thinks Georgia should still be in
the top four yahoo sports columnist
joins us now let me start with the fake
punt okay
judging from your reaction there is it a
bad decision before the result before
the end result there yes it's a terrible
decision for like five different reasons
absolutely fourth and eleven not fourth
and three tie game
you have the field position to pin them
deep your kicker is better than their
kicker if it comes down to a kicking
contest at the end and biggest reason of
all Alabama had its defense on the field
not a punt return team which you know
football people say that's an automatic
kill on the play call then you check out
of the fake when you see that the other
team has the defense out there and what
they call punt safe mode Saban Saban
brought that up basically which I think
his was his diplomatic way of saying I
can't believe Kirby did that is all
right I felt that if you're Georgia play
for overtime and if you had gone into
overtime then Georgia would be playing
in the Final Four what do you think yeah
you know that's that's a great thought
that really if you if you simply extend
the game that far that it does it makes
you look better because you did you did
take Alabama to ot you know and I know
that's that's a picture so big that I'm
sure it never occurred to Kirby Smart on
the sideline at that point in time again
yeah I might my stance is that I thought
Georgia was the fourth best team coming
in and I didn't see them do anything to
lose ground I came away more impressed
with Georgia after that game and I was
going in so that's why I would say but I
I looked at this and I don't know if the
committee is gonna factor this in the
four most deserving or the four best
because you Oklahoma deserved to be in
there winning their last game they won
the big 12 but are they better than
Georgia I don't think they are so I
don't know how the committee looks at
this and I know the LSU lost you know
that that's really what is keeping
Georgia out of this
are the four most deserving teams or the
four best teams what would you do well
this is the beautiful mess that is
college football as we get into this
syntactical debate of the difference
between best and most deserving and I
always my default position is Mike slide
the guy who was most responsible to make
the playoff happen the late SEC
Commissioner and the words that he
always drove home as the most important
words the four best teams and he was
very purposeful about it because he he
thought that there were plenty of years
that would mean at least two SEC but but
I I like that methodology that way of
thinking for best teams I want to see
the best teams to play the best games
because I have a feeling Oklahoma isn't
gonna push Alabama to the last minute of
the game on when they play in the Cotton
Bowl I'm sorry in the Orange Bowl what
do you think of and people were rooting
for chaos and then chaos brings change
and then maybe we have a 16 or 18
playoff can you have an 18 playoff and
get rid of the conference championship
games would love that love for that to
be the case I think you can I absolutely
think you can you know conferences love
their little commerce championships
games but they don't help the sport as a
whole and that's the big problem with
college football is each little fiefdom
only thinks about itself if you could do
away with the with the championship
games on that weekend and you had
Alabama hosting Washington in Tuscaloosa
and you had Oklahoma going to Georgia
and you had Ohio State Ohio State Notre
Dame in South Bend how good would that
weekend be I mean if you had those four
games you play one on Friday night a
triple header on Saturday it would be
awesome I just think it'd be great I
hope that there's enough contentiousness
and divisive miss that we you know push
the debate further and people at least
consider it
talking to Pat 440 from Yahoo Sports
they're college football in college
basketball columnist also looking at
Lincoln Riley some of these other
coaches who might move up to the pro
ranks or at least get an interview we
had Lincoln Riley on last hour
and I said is it do you have an
obligation to your family and yourself
to at least look at these jobs and he
said no I have a great job and I mean
that's the right answer to give me but
do you think Lincoln Reilly is coaching
in the NFL next season sure I would not
blame him if he looked I mean either a
brilliant yeah he's got a brilliant
offensive mind it's it's an offensive
mind it's more and more adaptable to the
NFL you know the line there used to be
such a blurred line I see a strong line
between the way you quarterback and
coached offense in college versus the
NFL in that line is blurred now and so I
you know I mean if I were the NFL team
I'd absolutely want to talk to him my
sense is that he's happy at Oklahoma and
would stay there but it wouldn't shock
me if he ended up in the NFL next season
was this a good year for college
football mmm that's a great question
because they're really good I mean how
many dramatic games have been you know
against you're like wow that was so
great I was so fun not that many you
know not that many huge upsets even when
Purdue stunned Ohio State that was a
twenty nine point game it was over by
the middle of the third quarter
Alabama's Jack stomped everybody
Clemson's Jack stomped everybody Notre
Dame has had some close games but you
know not necessarily overly memorably
close so from a drama standpoint it
hasn't been great I'm hoping we're going
to get there but it may take till the
last game because I think both semi
finals could be fairly laughs I would
Alabama losing in the first round be
good for a college football sure I think
though that would not be a problem
matter of fact both Alabama and Clemson
lost in the first round why not because
then if you've got fresh blood playing
for the championship I mean that would
that would certainly that would upset
the applecart to a degree it's been a
berry you know the playoff era has been
very formal it's been pretty much the
same the usual suspects in there and I
think that somewhat lessens the national
interest Urban Meyer is where next
season either an analyst on TV or
watching his kids grandkids do their
thing I don't think he's coaching good
to visit with you is always Pat we
appreciate your time thanks my pleasure
Dan Thank You Pat 40 Yahoo Sports for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]